disney
also disney all right fine one more time
since apparently no one is listening
if you want this to take place in 1986
just say 1986.
when i watch this in 2055 i don't want
to be wondering why no one is talking
about the pandemic or wearing masks
just set the flashbacks at a set time
you mealy-mouthed title cowards
one day that big beautiful wound
wrecking head of yours is going to dream
up fantastic things
i mean honestly the wrecking is probably
more vaginal or perineum related
so if you're going to casually alert
your child to the genital destruction
they've caused
let's be anatomically clear okay and do
you
know what modoc stands for i do
mental organism designed only for
killing which is technically modaf
so let's start there but also since as
my hard g
gif brethren have pointed out the
letters absolutely must match the words
they stand for i once again have to
point out that the
only starts with a hard o sound so
technically you should be called
modok and since i am to please motok it
is
purposely taunting the bad guy who has a
head laser after my aim soldiers destroy
the stock exchange on top of the economy
villain exposes plan to his foe instead
of killing them when he has the chance
cliche
and yes it's probably intentional but
even intentional sins are still a cliche
wait a minute strike that reverse it
are you binge watching the great british
bake off in your helmet while we fight
i mean the iron chef joke was right
there also not trying to start up the
who did it at first debate but lego
batman totally did this type of hero
villain stick first
no i'm savoring the great british bank
off making it last
no more than two episodes a day three
times tantric binge watching
spoiler sports aim advanced idea
mechanics
in that case i believe you mean i'm who
wants to touch me while i touch the boom
requesting a menage a butt in the
workplace without explicit consent
you're at the end of all my videos but
if you were streaming live why does your
play bar have an end length listed
magic lou why can't you just pick a
normal teenage boy theme
abracadabra shaming your mother's about
to volunteer to sleep on the couch so i
can spend the night in my marital bed
with iron man's boot
knocking boots eight million on the
hover bikes 20 million on the laser
cannon
show steals the concept of our what's
the damage video series without even
giving us attribution
i'm sorry i i thought this coffee was
for everyone
might be the funniest moment in the
episode with that being said this might
be the funniest moment in the episode
also maybe just maybe mod oaks had laser
cauterized the wound but do these guys
feel
pain or are they like me perusing the
youtube comments and just so used to the
constant torture that it barely
registers anymore
i have a very simple plan to save aim
i'm going to rob fort knox
if this show includes a scene with
modok's nude body on a bed painted in
gold i'm taking all the sins back
or adding them i'll make up my mind once
i see aim is
finished thing aol said in the early
2000s somehow makes it into this episode
no areas more sacred than modoc's
personal space prepare to suck
based on the box office i'm pretty sure
spiral has the monopoly on sawsucking
i still don't have a bar mitzvah suit
i'm looking for the right fabric do you
mind if i have a
feel real quick of the same material you
were literally just touching it
dad one of your dumbasses spilled acid
all over my boyfriend
i feel like this show is basically a
bunch of quick jokes that are onto the
next
joke before you have time to realize
that the last joke probably wasn't funny
i'm not saying that style of comedy
can't be fun i'm just saying you
probably now owe us royalties
okay you got me i'm a huge fan
but since we find out later that austin
bought this toy to get on modok's good
side how did he know motok would look in
the drawer what if he wasn't a drawer
peeper what was austin's plan at that
point
unaware that you were facing off on the
frenetic pommel horse with the gabby
douglas of mental gymnastics
using gabby douglas instead of simone
biles as your gymnast metaphor
look gabby's great but simone does
things that are so impossible and iconic
that she literally has four different
gymnastic moves named after her and i'm
even
using literally in that sense as
language god intended
what is all of this a lot of things that
grumble would never be able to get set
up in a day's time at
i'm by golly i believe it is this is
goleen seven gray seven grains is too
many grains for one cereal
modok would kill it at serial sins what
happened to my torture chamber rumble
had it changed to a daycare
so it's basically the same then murder
murder that birder was someone's
daughter and now it's been murdered when
i'm done you won't even miss that eye
sore
i'm not going to spend a ton of time on
this because well i don't want to
but that pain should have disintegrated
completely and even if it didn't the
dude was holding it off to his right so
it would just have sprayed directly on
the back wall and even if it did spray
evenly across where the human was the
human wasn't there anymore
look i don't have time to draw a diagram
but i feel good sending it so that
outline is a lie
cut print check the send gate moving on
well you vaporized an outside contractor
that's your first strike
modok also just threatened the life of
his boss when he said i
want to chemically castrate austin so
he's gotta have at least two strikes
right i cannot believe they laid us all
off
speaking of being laid off why are you
still in your uniforms those would be
grumble owned now
we're doing a mine heist baby
christopher nolan's motok
even if they didn't spot him do they not
clean the room up at night why would
they just leave this forest creature
orgy in the middle of the room
i modoc reverse engineered pym particles
see see you mentioned pym particles it's
a marvel thing so the show is super cool
now
change your pantaloons marvel nerds you
have soiled them
stress passing on company grounds in
fact
no moto g hasn't been fired now let's
get small post coital pep talks
this'll just take a moment i mean you
should be correct but it turns out the
show needs to have a moto
takes over his wife's body to build
relational tension moment before you can
complete the paperwork
so you just sign super slow and it will
all be all right
i'm so sorry i seem to have lost control
on my body so moto can now use this
brain control device to replicate
perfect martial arts and gymnastic
techniques even though there's no
indication that jody's body has been
trained for any of this
that's quite an upgrade you want me to
play ball
here the tablet you're so horny for this
works
[Music]
i haven't seen the rest of the series
but i feel very comfortable calling this
premature celebration
i mean i want a divorce i don't know if
i should add a sin for bringing divorce
into my superhero show or commend it i
also don't know if i'm all right with
how emotional this makes me
because i'm not crying over robot
chicken motok i'm not you can't make
me just look away i know mobro is going
through some stuff here but can we find
out why this couple behind him is just
sitting silently staring at the wall
together are they okay
can someone check for a pulse blink
twice if you can hear me stevenson's
just blink twice
i'm not kidding it's like an orange on a
toothpick pushing the boundaries of
science
torture and advanced
all weaponry us except the ones who are
dead
baby steps monica baby steps
baby steps baby steps through the office
they called me big head he'll be crying
himself to sleep tonight on his huge
pillow
tis but a scratch i'm recommending a
three-day forced sabbatical
suspension you've got to be shooting me
no i'm terminating your employment i
need your badge
well i need you to stop sweating through
your shirts and grossing everybody out
i'll call out your name during sex
instead of mine i think about
[ __ ] a lot